before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
you know um
this jacket's a little more snug in the
chest than it used to be
[Music]
well for now the second week in a row
russell t davis has decided to drop
major doctor who knows or or at least
his era has although he was quoted in it
as well so
like
i should just plan to
not have my weekends to me anymore or at
least uh have the start of my work week
completely obliterated from being able
to plan anything just deal with whatever
doctor who news there is
so
it has been confirmed that both david
tennant and katherine tate
are returning
as the doctor and donna
for the 60th anniversary special to air
in 2023
so this
is big news
donna has not been seen on the show
since the end of time part two
which was the last of the david tennant
specials between series four and series
five
and tenent has not taken on the role
since the day of the doctor which aired
as a number of specials in between
uh series
seven and eight so it's been a while for
both of them
and this is obviously
very exciting a lot of people have been
saying that they would like to see
either or both of these characters back
and there is a lot of rampant
speculation going on including some
really bizarre
stuff so i'm gonna deal with some of
that quickly because as absurd as as it
is i've seen it
suggested in multiple places so let's
deal with a couple of things
i have no conception of why anyone would
think that david tennant is coming in to
play anyone other than the tenth doctor
which was who he already played there's
one other minor possibility put an
asterisk on it but i'm mostly gonna be
addressing that i'm surprised they
haven't done this but i don't think it
is but i'll come back to that but i've
seen people flat out suggest well you
know
maybe tenet will be the 14th doctor for
the course of the special and then he'll
regenerate into shooti gatwa and
he'll actually be the 15th because you
know when they announced that
shrutigatwa was going to be the doctor
they didn't say the 14th doctor they
just said the doctor no they did say the
14th doctor the official announcement
on the official doctor who page of the
bbc
says 14th doctor so scrap all the
nonsense i know i know a lot of you are
still trying to work your fan theories
as to how david tennant was going to
come back and be the doctor again or the
valley art or something you're trying to
retrofit them into the new just stop
please
ah
that said we don't know a lot of the
specifics about how this is gonna work
russell c davies himself has been very
coy
about this floating all kinds of stuff
and basically saying well
maybe this is a missing story from the
time when they were together maybe it's
an alternate timeline maybe it's a dream
maybe it's a flashback so he's playing
coy right now in terms of what this
actually is or how big of a part it is
going to be in the story because that's
the other thing when dealing in
multi-doctor stories the amount of time
that any given doctor gets
can range wildly you can get your um you
know your instances like you know the
two doctors or even the day of the
doctor with a tenant the war doctor and
the 11th doctor but you know there were
also these tiny little snippets of a
bunch of other doctors including capaldi
that was kind of the debut where he
debuted his attack eyebrows so the size
and scope varies wildly that said i'm
not sure i'm going to expect it to be
super
small then there's the other speculation
like ooh who else is going to be back
i'm going to float this right now i
don't think anyone else is going to be
back
not anyone else major
like there might be other characters who
haven't shown up in a while but i don't
think we're gonna get any other doctors
as far as viable options go um you know
they we have a number of living doctors
but uh tom baker already made what i
think feels a bit like a very
appropriate final appearance uh in day
of the doctor peter davison has already
uh appeared with
the time crash short so he's kind of
accounted for here colin baker sylvester
mccoy
paul mcgann like
maybe
but if they're really trying to push
you know sort of reinvigorating the
modern era of doctor who it would make
more sense to pull from the modern era
for doctors eccleston won't work with
davies that seems still at this point
pretty clear i would be very shocked if
that ever happened and matt smith while
not out of the realm of possibilities
never worked with davey so he wouldn't
have the inclination and the pull to
come back
that um david tennant would similarly
with peter capaldi that doesn't take
them out of the running but it does make
david tennant a much more obvious pick
with rtd coming back
the other reason that i think there
probably won't be anybody else really of
note coming back is that
if you're bringing back
the most popular doctor and companion
pairing i'm going off of ratings which
is how someone like
an organization like the bbc would look
at it ratings wise series 4 was the most
popular most successful series of modern
era doctor who
so
bringing them back
is kind of all you need and you don't
necessarily want to dilute their impact
not to mention there's a lot of
logistics to cover if they're bringing
donna back in anything other than like a
this was an adventure they went on
during their normal time but we hadn't
seen it before because of the situation
that donna was left in at the end of her
tenure where she
spoilers four years ago um where she
does not remember the doctor anymore and
she can't
it will kill her to remember him
so
that's always been sort of the big
sticking point the idea of bringing back
donald noble
but
given that davis himself is floating all
these other possibilities there yeah
there are ways around that now i
mentioned before like one possibility of
who david tennant could be other than
the 10th doctor
and it is something that i am kind of
still surprised the trigger has not been
pulled on and that's the metacrisis
doctor that's the doctor that went off
with rose because my honest assumption
when that happened was always oh that's
so they can bring david tennant back
later and not have to worry about
accounting for the fact that he is
visibly aged
except he hasn't really visibly aged i
think he i think he might very well be
an immortal vampire or a highlander so
that hasn't happened and i ever need to
pull the trigger on that but the main
reason i don't think that's gonna come
into play is that that doctor while
you know that came about during the time
when the doctor was with donna that
doctor is connected to rose
not specifically to donna and so i think
the things you'd have to cover to have
it be the meta crisis doctor and donna
i don't know that seems like a lot of
unnecessary narrative hoops to jump
through when you could just have it be
you know the main universe
uh 10th doctor and donna and while there
are still things to overcome logistical
hurdles to deal with that'll probably be
a lot cleaner and you don't want to bog
out down too much of the story in
technobabble explaining how the story's
even allowed to happen in the first
place
so am i excited about this
i don't know
i'm nervous is what i am
don is my favorite companion and while
tennant is not my favorite doctor he is
the best
when he is with donna and series 4
um has
historically been my favorite series
it's currently sitting in my second
favorite series of modern era doctor who
i like series 4 a lot i like these two
together a lot so what's the problem
well
frankly i'm very worried about over
shadowing
shootigatoa and i don't mean that in a
sense of like he can't hold his own
against tenant i'm sure he'll do fine i
don't think
davis would have cast him if he thought
he couldn't hold his own with another
doctor it's more an issue of
if you're gonna give the fandom
the new doctor but also the old favorite
then the new doctor's really not gonna
get the focus that maybe he needs or
deserves
now
here's the thing at time of recording as
best as i could find if this has been
confirmed somewhere i could not find it
i found various references to it but
nothing that really cited a source
definitively that seemed trustworthy to
me and that is this
we don't know
if the 60th anniversary to air in 2023
presumably
in november
uh that's just based off being as close
to the actual anniversary as possible
we don't know if that will be the first
story in which trutiga will appear and
play the doctor
however most things kind of indicate
indicate and lean towards that
being the case
we're too far along in the year most
likely for them to throw together a
um
a holiday or a new year's
christmas or a new year special i'd be
very surprised if that ended up
happening i had kind of been holding out
hope that we would get series 14
whenever that airs before
the 60th anniversary special
but there really isn't a ton of
indication that that is going on in the
works because
so here's the thing
in terms of the timing of this
announcement there is a very good chance
and because this has happened
historically with doctor who in terms of
announcing guest stars
they generally announce them shortly
before filming begins
because once they start shooting
especially if they have anything that
gets shot in an area accessible to the
public it's gonna end up leaking
because people will see oh
there's david tennant in the pinstripe
and oh my gosh he's with catherine tate
somebody will see that somebody will
take a cell phone picture of it
so you announce it ahead of when you
start the shooting so that you get to
announce it and it's not leaked
the thing is
while the indication was generally
speaking that shitty gagwa probably got
announced when and in the way that he
did to get ahead of a leak i still
believe that's probably the case
there's been no indication of him being
involved in shooting yet
definitely not enough to have gotten
like a special shot or what have you
and
things seem to indicate right now and a
lot of places seem to believe and i
don't have a reason to doubt this other
than my own i wish it wasn't true
that the 60th anniversary is gonna be
his first outing as the doctor
and i just feel like that's
i don't want to say completely bungling
the first impression
but it's going to be really difficult
to find a way
to have him shine
and show what he's going to bring to the
doctor and give him the spotlight which
any doctor should have in their first
story
while also
not leaving a bunch of long time fans
annoyed and feeling like you wasted or
underused david tennant and catherine
tate because if you're gonna bring them
back you kind of should do something
pretty momentous with them and those are
two creative interests that are very at
odds
because if you're gonna bring these two
back you better do something big with
them but if you do something big with
them how are you going to properly
introduce and deliver and sell
this new doctor
when this has to take so much
time
attention priority
is it impossible to balance no
but
it's a setup that concerns me now
my hope here
is that my inclination that the 60th
anniversary is going to be the next
doctor who episode proper after the
centenary special which will be in
october and that's jody whittaker's last
appearance
that there will be something in between
whether it's a special
like
you know
like i said at this point probably too
late for them to throw together
christmas or new year but you want to do
another easter special you do that
davies did an easter special planet of
the dead was an easter special you could
do that
it's probably too much to hope for a
full series
you know all of series 14.
but
that's my hope
that we get something
something to give us a good
spotlight
get us a chance
to fall in love with this doctor
without the ex
also being in the room the x that a lot
of people are still pining for
i know i just turned doctor who and
watching doctor who into a relationship
metaphor but i hope you followed my
thinking on that
until
such time as it is 100 confirmed
that the 60th anniversary is or is not
uh gathwa's first appearance as the
doctor
i'm going to be nervous to find out
what's the case once i know for certain
either way
i'll either still be nervous because it
will be his first episode and i'll be
worried about the outcome of that or
i'll be relieved because it's not
but as i said most things that i can
find right now seem to indicate that
that's the path that's likely to go
and yeah that makes me nervous
and i don't want to feel nervous
because i
like tennant and i love
catherine tate i love donna
oh
nerves we'll see what happens as we get
more information probably dropped on a
sunday again
but i'm not planning on shooting
and bumping my entire schedule for the
week i whack as i edit this and get this
uploaded in the following morning
[Music]
davies
stop messing with me
in any case what do you think about this
announcement whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it like share subscribe
the patreon is what pays the bills and
means that wow i [ __ ] about my schedule
being rearranged i am still able to get
these out relatively quickly because
this doesn't have to compete with an
office job this is my living and the
patreon is what allows that to be the
case any amount you can help is of great
assistance there's a discord server
which is a patreon exclusive perk where
yeah people have been talking about this
with uh other geeks and whatnot but you
know
there's other perks and all that stuff
don't worry too much about it though the
like share subscribe also help me out
but
don't worry about that either
the thing i really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings
and until
the next
last minute doctor who announcement
this council is adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin lutfalla turak oliver b melinda
walters
the oath of boy tt for knobby lax the
poodle zach paul idoln tracy scrapbot
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
toku bl whovian adam rdl taylor shane
ross shaylee gourley and brendan larose
you want to hear me mispronounce your
name check out rewards on the patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]
you
[Music]